but how do you know where the bottom is
and where the top is because you know
the warren buffets of the world or the
great investors of all time will say
just stay for the long game you never
you can't time the market it's not about
timing the market it's about time
in the market don't day trade decade
trade so how do you figure that out he's
not in the same market i'm in and if he
was in this market i smoke him
but in his market he smoked me
so it's like warren buffett dude well
here's the thing right
warren buffett's tactics are to buy
something and never sell it which gives
you a tax advantage
so if you're if you're taxed at the
corporate rate i don't remember exactly
what it is but let's say it's 20 percent
and the
return on investment in stocks to say
let's average 10 percent
you're making an extra 2 a year by never
selling because you
you have extra money in the market
because you weren't taxed because you
didn't sell and so if you buy a thing
like coca-cola that tends to have
product market fit a walled garden
it's it's not a volatile industry it's
likely to be popular for a very long
time
so he buys gillette he buys coca-cola he
buys things that have mcdonald's apple
boring exactly he's a tradition the
apple thing's nick if there's anyone
that is the exact opposite of warren
buffett i think it would be richard hart
true yeah in terms of but
his idea was someone else at his company
that correct you know he has to either
he's gonna die he's gonna die and then
he has to hand it off the next guy so
the next guy might as well get
experience
so
the issue is like why do i care about
warren buffett or the stock market when
it only did a 2x in 14 years you had to
wait 14 years to get a 2x in the s p 500
and this is with all-time high inflation
with zero percent interest rates with
money printing out the yin yang
you couldn't have had a better macro
environment for stocks to appreciate and
so the s p 500 in this environment where
you know if you adjust for inflation
it's not even that good like if you
adjust for inflation you didn't get a 2x
and so why would i care about 14 years
wait for a 2x
when i can get that in a month on crypto
like hex just went up 2x in
the last month
so do you want to wait 14 years or do
you want to wait 30 days it's really
that easy and i don't and like all this
other stuff i don't care i don't care
like it's probably
how long how much
did you start hex
uh a thousand days ago a thousand days
ago yeah so three years ago yeah give or
take 2.2 prior to
hex where were you putting your money
well i never talk about my money but i
can say that you know i mined bitcoin at
50 cents um i bought bitcoin at 30. it
went directly down to two so that drop
that was a 93.5 percent drop instantly
yeah but i wish i bought more than 2000
i wish i'd bought the dip imagine if i
bought the dip that would be much nicer
right like you can if you just 2x your
investment on a 90 dip you 10 extra
stack so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]